la fragmentation des habitats menace la
survie des espèces c'est le cas du
Grizzly qui est à deux doigts
disparaître chez nos voisins du sud la
solution reconnectez le territoire
veuillez le Stone au Yukon c'est le
projet white l'objectif créer un immense
corridor qui permet à la faune de migrer
de se nourrir et de se reproduire
voici le réseau d'air protégé pour y
arriver il a fallu la collaboration du
Canada et des États-Unis mais pas
seulement les citoyens ont choisi de
protéger des milliers d'hectares de
terres privées
la création d'une centaine de passages
phoniques permet aux animaux de se
déplacer en toute sécurité en 30 ans les
grizzly américains sont devenus quatre
fois plus nombreux
caribou lynx loup en anticipé un des
plus grands modèles de conservation au
monde la clé du succès la coopération